[Musique]
chez Sandy dans la commune de
Saint-Pierre
usine allez viens
en forme merci Sandy
et du coup bah il fait que Yaga
passe le relais à quelqu'un de la
famille et du coup
c'est le rôle d'un Charette
utilisé pour transport
tout ce qui avait à transporter à
l'époque marchandise canne à sucre roche
des rivières tout ça même les récupérer
à l'air chaud comment le corail
et du coup bah l'été le moyen de
transport de Lille jusqu'à les camions
tracteurs arrivés ça c'est le bœuf à
l'état d'origine et là on a à côté
croisé zébu Madagascar il ressemble un
petit peu mais son cousin d'accord et
aujourd'hui à où que ça vous fait avec
ce Charet de bœuf là aujourd'hui ben oui
mais essaie de perpétuer tradition là et
du coup marteau va fallait créer un
activité autour et dans la création de
cette activité là ils ont aussi ça
promène les gens les touristes les
Marmettes
un petit peu comment il fonctionne et
puis comment elles ont réussi à
travailler la canne autrefois avant
toute mécanisation que l'on a
actuellement c'est quelque chose que
vous trouvera plus loin et toute ma
détient de mon grand-père c'est lilas
mon frère reste trop de vacances
un seul taureau sur le petit facilement
3 tonnes le plat Sandy histoires
depuis mitchengage de goutte l'ambiance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et que ça te fait des missions
allez salut
et ben voilà notre émission
et un gagiste la case mais les pas finie
la Réunion Philippe de case et d'autres
trésors
[Musique]
toute mon trésor ma beauté ma beauté ma
pote est loquée à mon moment
ça me soulier
oui mon cœur tu es ma tiens bon maintien
beau matin